alguna vez te han dicho tienes que
confiar en ti y lo vas a lograr seguro
que sí pero cuántas veces realmente lo
has puesto en práctica cuantas veces
realmente has confiado la confianza se
define por la rae como seguridad que se
tiene de sí misma esperanza firme que se
tiene de alguien o algo o aliento o
ánimo para obrar todas estas
definiciones son muy buenas pero no creo
que apliquemos todas cuando nos dicen
confía te imaginas lo que se puede hacer
con un solo ingrediente con el poder de
la confianza me llamo rosa reyna
gonzález cancino tengo 23 años y hoy
quiero convencerte de que con un solo
ingrediente con el poder de la confianza
puedes lograr grandes cosas y se trata
solamente de explotarlo
el primer tipo de confianza la pude
descubrir cuando yo decidí estudiar la
carrera que elegí estudia ingeniería
aeroespacial en un país
esa misma cara que hiciste tú la
hicieron mis papás cuando les dije lo
que quería estudiar seguido de un porque
no esto ya es algo normal te vas a morir
de hambre
ouch definitivamente no son las palabras
de apoyo que quieres escuchar pero
pronto tuve que tomar una decisión entre
estudiar una carrera fácil que pudiera
darme un trabajo pronto o estudiar algo
que fuera perseguir mis sueños y
entonces dentro del primer voto de
confianza el voto de confianza en mí
misma decidí confiar en mí y aunque
sabía que no era fácil no iba a lograr
en tan solo primer semestre de la
carrera me postularon para hacer un
estudiante que pudiera asistir a un
campamento de houston de la nasa en este
campamento tuvimos que planear una
misión a marte el día de la revisión de
la misión con las asesores de nasa me
hicieron la pregunta porque nada
quisiera trabajar con méxico y yo no
supe responder
me enojo que él no creyera que méxico es
competente para trabajar en este tipo de
proyectos pero me enojo más el hecho de
que yo no supe responderle y regresé a
méxico con una nueva misión cervezas
razones por las cuales otros países
quisieran colaborar con méxico al llegar
a puebla me enteré que opaep estaría
trabajando en un nuevo satélite en
colaboración con nasa y la agencia
espacial mexicana y estaban reclutando
estudiantes yo tenía que ser parte de
ese proyecto
el proyecto empezó en 2017 y terminó el
pasado año 2020 logrando la misión con
éxito andrés martínez el director de
nasa del proyecto quien confía en un
pase para darles esta misión pero fue
antes upaep quien confía en sus
estudiantes y profesores para dar los
recursos de esta misión sabiendo que
vamos a lograrlo de alguna u otra manera
este tipo de confianza es la segunda y
para mí es la más poderosa que es la que
se otorga tu no sabes el impacto que
puede tener en alguien al confiar en él
o en ella pero a veces puedes
transformar les la vida y todo empieza
así con un voto de confianza al empezar
el proyecto rápidamente tuve que hacer
uso de mi poder no empieza sabiendo nada
pero tienes que saberlo todo y yo
confiaba en que podía lograrlo
la lección más valiosa que me llevo de
este proyecto es el trabajo en equipo si
un equipo no está trabajando bien algún
pilar no está trabajando bien nada del
proyecto funciona
a tan solo tres meses de estar en el
proyecto en el equipo de estructura
mecánica
el profesor líder del equipo me ofreció
a ser la estudiante líder yo no sabía
por qué me había elegido a mí porque
habían estudiantes de semestres mucho
más avanzados que tenían más
conocimientos que yo pero él confía en
mí y yo dije que sí y aquí fue cuando
pude definir mi propia definición de
liderazgo saber confiar en tu equipo en
un buen líder no es el que hace todo
sino es quien ve las virtudes en sus
integrantes y puede depositar las tareas
no todo es color de rosa una vez que
empieza el trabajo pesado las horas en
el cuarto limpio pasan en cámara lenta y
aumenta tu carga de trabajo te empiezas
a hacer preguntas cómo podré lograrlo y
aquí te va un consejo que te voy a dar
en toda la vida
rodéate de personas y confíen en ti a
veces las simples palabras tú puedes te
pueden ayudar a terminar la carrera a
seguir en el proyecto oa lograr
cualquier meta y gracias a los amigos
que confiaban en mí yo no desistir el
proyecto
al llegar la etapa de lanzamiento me
ofrecieron la oportunidad de ir a cabo
cañaveral en florida a presenciar el
lanzamiento del satélite la verdad yo no
sabía porque me habían elegido a mí pero
la maestra erika sevilla confíe en mí y
yo dije que sí una vez allá nos dijeron
que íbamos a participar en una rueda de
prensa del satélite y querían que yo
pasara como la estudiante representante
del equipo y les practicará sobre
nuestro proyecto la verdad sentía un
miedo terrible empecé a preguntarme
cosas como seré capaz y si lo digo todo
mal y si se me olvida el inglés pero
también dije y si si lo hago y todo sale
bien y una vez más dije que sí
el día de la presentación tuve que sacar
el tipo de confianza que se parece a la
autoestima yo quería que todos supieran
que no había no se habían equivocado al
confiar en mí y yo quería demostrarles
que habían hecho una buena elección
presente junto a andrés martínez quien
es el director de nuestro proyecto junto
a mentes super brillantes científicos
ingenieros maestros y yo era la única
estudiante ahí antes de presentar
respire profundo y dije confía en ti y
lo vas a lograr y ese día me marcó para
siempre
al terminar la presentación los medios
de naza se acercaron con nosotros
querían saber más de nuestro satélite
el primero 100 mexicano desplegado desde
la estación espacial internacional la
verdad es que para mí yo no había hecho
la gran cosa pero para ello sí lo fue y
ese día la lección más importante que me
llevé fue confía en el valor de tu
trabajo si tú no ves el valor en tu
trabajo nadie más lo va a ver después de
la rueda de prensa nos pidieron dar
algunas entrevistas darles palabras de
aliento a los niños que querían estudiar
algo relacionado en el campo stem
ese día entendí el tercer tipo de
confianza y así cuando tú cumples un
sueño no es solamente para realización
personal sino es para servir de
inspiración a otros para que cumplan sus
sueños y esa fue mi nueva misión quería
ayudar a más personas a perseguir sus
sueños dándoles la confianza que a mí me
no me dieron cuando yo quería empezar
esta aventura
los días siguientes fueron increíbles
tuvimos un tour vip y por las
instalaciones de nasa nos llevaron a las
plataformas de lanzamiento y al edificio
donde ensamblan a los cohetes y el 5 de
diciembre a las 12 28 pude presenciar lo
más hermoso que he visto el despegue del
falcon 9 de spacex llevando a nuestro
satélite a bordo de la cápsula dragón
hacia el espacio
ese día valió la pena todas las horas de
trabajo los desvelos pero aún no
habíamos logrado la misión y es que aún
teníamos que saber si nuestro satélite
realmente funcionaba pero nosotros como
estudiantes queríamos pensar que si
bueno no más bien confiamos en que si
funcionaría porque habíamos hecho un
buen trabajo el 27 de febrero fue la
hora de la verdad 40 minutos después de
que el satélite fue expulsado por la
caja de nano racks nos dio una señal de
vida y ahora sí lo habíamos logrado
el satélite fue resultado sí de muchas
horas de trabajo de constante esfuerzo
de muchas normas licencias permisos de
recursos pero sobre todo fue resultado
de un grupo de personas que confiaron en
que podíamos hacerlo la confianza te
hace decir que si te permite hacer el sí
que otra persona necesita y te permite
contagiar está confianza como reacción
en cadena el poder o la confianza está
dentro de ti listo para ser explotado
pero tú tienes que ser el primer voto de
confianza confiar en ti mismo así que te
dejo con este consejo tienes que confiar
en ti y lo vas a lograr gracias